hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my Walking Dead episode 9 video
really solid Tyrese episode it is
basically like a recap of everything
that's happened and it was telling us
where they're going next that was what
was up with the weird title what
happened and what's going on that's
almost a little too on the nose for me
but maybe you guys liked it because we
went to wilt shirt Estates and that's a
big place from the comics I'm gonna
explain what that is I'm gonna explain
that storyline in the comics just
because it happened a long time ago like
season 1 timeline they just they skipped
over it on the TV show ok so just
careful for spoilers from the episode if
you haven't seen it yet starting with
Wiltshire estates in the episode it's
Noah's home he probably told them about
it that it was a good place to live that
they might be able to stay there and
he's supposed to still have family there
he doesn't know that they're dead until
they get there in the comics they
actually stay there for a while they
they just happen upon it while it's
wintertime it's really cold they need
food so they use it as shelter as you'd
imagine things go bad just like they do
in this episode the relative composition
of the group was a little bit different
Tyreese and Carol they're together
Andrea Dale Alan and Donna so because I
feel like they were trying to honor the
comic book storyline I feel like that's
why Rick talked to Carol on the radio
and instead of Tyreese leading it it was
actually Donna that died so it's just
like one of the many locations where the
group stays for an extended period of
time
this episode was more of a layover
though like a jumping-off point before
they go to Washington DC which is also
another big comic book place a couple
other big Easter eggs in the episode
like Tyreese losing his hand as well as
the baseball bat
I don't know necessarily that those were
intentional Easter eggs they could be
foreshadowing for the future there's
this picture of Norman Reedus you know
holding a cut-off hand obviously that's
not tyreese's so somebody else this
season might lose at hand right now
Abraham's at the top of that list cuz he
still has that giant wound on his hand
that keeps getting worse okay so here we
go top five moments number five Tyreese
explains his childhood it's always fun
to listen to the characters talk about
themselves Terry said the awesome speech
about his dad I feel like his dad would
have been a person who would have
survived in the apocalypse he sounded
like he knew what was up it's all about
paying the high cost of living keeping
your eyes open understanding what's
going on where things are headed face
your fears which obviously Tyreese
proceeds to do through the course of the
episode it provides a nice metaphor for
where the group is at right now
like they all collectively have to face
their fears and push forward it also
kind of implies that they're gonna have
to start paying attention to what's
going on in the rest of the world not
just that little corner of Georgia where
they've been when you think about it the
narrative so far has been very
self-contained to just that one state
that's why I think people are excited
about the spinoff because it's gonna be
in Los Angeles it'll be like a
completely different place so you get a
completely different perspective quick
side note that that's suburban they were
driving in the Chevy Suburban I had
several friends with dads that all had
Suburbans just like that it's just a
funny thought because they're on their
road trip radioing back and forth they
clearly they have a caravan going on
that's why they were radioing each other
moving on to number four welcome to
Wiltshire estates everyone is dead know
what kind of goes through the stages of
grief just like all the other members of
the group had before at some point
they've all visited the places where
they came from and found everyone dead
so they all had that moment that's
that's why Tyreese was just kind of
awkwardly shaking his head like yeah
yeah one thing I thought was interesting
is is when they were deciding that they
probably should not stay there when they
started to argue about it and they went
outside and saw those hacked-up bodies
it looked like someone had tried to
break in with gunfire like it looked
like there were scorch marks on the
outsides of those walls a lot of you
guys were asking me on Twitter if I
thought it might be me Jen Savior's just
because of the baseball bat I don't
think it was them I think the people
that live there just set those walkers
on fire they tried to burn them and then
the walkers just kept pounding on the
outside of the wall so I don't think
someone was invading with a cannon like
governor style with the tank moving out
to number three in remembrance of Beth
Emily Kinney had that song in the
episode I actually think that's one of
her own songs like an actual song that
she wrote in real life that feels like
something really nice from behind the
scenes they let her do like well we're
gonna kill you off but you're starting
your music career so we'll give you a
nice bump by putting your song on the
show Glenn and Rick also talked a lot
about her as if she were still alive
they would have gone there and stayed
for her or at least that they would try
to fulfill Beth's dream of living in a
place like that in a place that felt
like home Beth is dead so it doesn't
feel like home anymore
and everyone else is dead so it's
literally not home in the comics
whenever they come on Wiltshire estates
it's like a big victory for them they're
really happy it's really exciting in
this episode it was really depressing it
was like a really sad moment when they
found it moving on to number two the sad
train continues as Tyreese and Noah go
back to Noah's
house did anyone else feel like the
minute Noah got up and ran away from
Tyrese everything was gonna go to [ __ ]
it's like he's violating the rules of a
zombie apocalypse movie you never run
away from the group on your own
especially when everything is creepy
quiet the woman on the floor looked like
his mother and obviously it was his twin
younger brothers the Tyrese ran afoul of
it was really hard to parse what was
going through his brain when he was
staring at those pictures when Tyrese
was staring at the pictures of his
younger brothers was he looking at those
what was this creepy look on his face
him thinking about Mika and Lizzy or was
he thinking about his childhood the
minute he noticed that there were two of
them though like you just knew that yeah
the one that's bumping the door in the
bathroom that that's the other one and
my number one moment obviously Tyrese
bites the dust' didn't you just wonder
the minute he walked past those shark
jaws in the background like up this is
this is not gonna end well initially I
definitely didn't think he was gonna die
I know we were all kind of wondering
whether or not he was gonna live or die
or what was gonna happen the minute he
got bit because there's really only a
couple things you can do if the bite
isn't that bad yeah you could have cut
the arm off and he would have been fine
but that was a giant chunk and they
didn't get to him for several minutes so
I think he died because he lost so much
blood not because of the Walker virus
and when they pulled over later in the
car I do think he had started to turn so
they pulled him out and they finished
him off didn't you feel like though when
they started pulling away in the car
like oh they might be able to salvage
this this might be okay and yank him out
of the car then it's like okay nope this
is over this is done it wouldn't be a
Walking Dead premiere or finale if they
didn't kill somebody
maybe Tyrese can go on Game of Thrones
in a future season here they also steal
a lot of actors from the wire just in
terms of cinematography though I just I
can't not talk about all the visions
that Tyrese had in talking to all the
dead people
the governor was so great I was trying
to think of it in the context of like it
ego super-ego but I think it was simpler
than that I think it was his brain
processing his regrets he regrets what
he did for the governor he regrets what
he did to Mika and Lizzie even though he
technically didn't do anything to them
that was all Carol everyone regrets Beth
so I feel like if everyone had a version
of this scene Beth would be in each one
of there's also the way they
transitioned between real life and his
visions was really awesome like the way
Lizzie started pulling on his arm and it
turned into Andrew Lincoln speaking of
which I think the British voice on that
radio was actually Andrew Lincoln I
think he was the one that was doing that
just fun behind the
scenes facts so here's my big question
for you guys we know they're going to
Washington now but how did you feel
about tyreese's death would you have
rather seen someone else die did you
want to see Noah die I'll be honest I
kind of did want to see Noah die I'm
totally fine with Tyler James Williams
but I don't like him as much as Chad
Coleman so regardless of where they're
trying to take the show and the
characters I think they wouldn't keep
the Noah character on if he was not
critical to the back half of the plot
also I think they want to keep some
young blood in the shows like right now
Glenn seems like the youngest even
though he's about the same age as Maggie
and they're not that young
so now Noah is like the noob survivor so
expect him to get a lot of like
explainer scenes from the other
characters where they teach him about
how to survive in the apocalypse if I
were Noah and I was going to apprentice
to anyone in the group I mean I probably
stick with Daryl or Carol they just feel
like they do the best job of surviving
on their own the other members of the
group all very capable but feel like
they need other people to survive and
Carol feels like she does okay on her
own and Daryl to Gerald's kind of a
loner let me know if you guys thought
there was anything that was just really
off about the episode and do you think
that that baseball bat is a negan Easter
ray I'm thinking that's way way far off
so I don't think it was meant to say
yeah we're gonna see this person in the
next four or five episodes maybe season
six we'll see maybe season six so
there's a new round of the giveaway
starting now all you have to do to enter
is be a subscriber and leave a comment
on this video I'll announce the winner
in my Q&A tomorrow and there's like some
weird subscription problem going on with
YouTube so just check like my Facebook
or Twitter page or my videos page if
you're not seeing the new videos show up
while you guys wait for the Q&A you can
click here I just I ranked all the
episodes from the first half of the
season and you can click here for the
Game of Thrones behind-the-scenes
special thank you so much for watching
so let's all high-five I'll see you guys
tomorrow
you